our top story this morning the deadly
and destructive flooding in West
Virginia the death toll there has
climbed to 23 and is expected to
increase West Virginia's governor has
called in hundreds of National Guardsmen
to help with search and rescue efforts
the flooding destroyed several homes as
some torn from foundations and carried
away by the swollen rivers and lakes the
trouble began on Thursday from heavy
rains on Friday the body of a four year
old boy was recovered after he was swept
away in floodwaters just outside his
home Kris Van Cleave has more from the
hard-hit community of White Sulphur
Springs Kris good morning good morning
you can see the damage the Howard Creek
did when it was raging debris is
scattered as far as I can see homes have
been destroyed and police here in
Greenbrier County say the bulk of those
people who died in this storm
lived here this is ridiculous this is
all that's left of Chad Adler's home
it's completely gone swept away by
raging floodwaters Thursday night that
tore through West Virginia seemingly out
of nowhere pieces of the home next door
ended up blocks away on the city's ball
field I figured it would be something
left
you know something standing but there's
nothing this is Vicky whit's home the
flood ripped apart her neighbor's house
and sent it crashing into hers across
the state at least 100 homes have been
seriously damaged or destroyed
it appears the river took over this
mobile home park and this house is
resting partially in the street next to
overturned cars roads have been ripped
apart and tens of thousands or without
power in just this one neighborhood in
the small community of White Sulphur
Springs we counted more than a dozen
homes destroyed city police and
paramedics spent Friday going
door-to-door looking for survivors or
worse everyone knew it was gonna ring
but no one knew they were
gonna be as devastating as it was mayor
lloyd Haynes I can't even describe how
heartbreaking it was and the waters
rushing down to you and there's nothing
you can do to help people at least four
of the dead are City residents who were
pulled from their homes into Howard
Creek do you feel lucky to be alive
oh yes very lucky mother of five Nicole
Lewis was nearly one of them but she
managed to grab hold of this tree and
withstand the punishing current for
three hours that had to be a tremendous
amount of strength how did you do that I
don't know I just prayed to God and just
kept my kids thinking about them I had
people over here talking to me you know
saying they were calling trying to get
help and I just held on it was a couple
of times that I thought I was gone the
National Weather Service expected the
rivers in West Virginia to crest
overnight the creek here has been
dropping for about the last 24 hours so
focus increasingly on the cleanup here
still when you look at the 23 people
dead that's more than the people killed
by tornadoes and lightning so far this
year combined ann-marie so much
devastation Kris Van Cleave in White
Sulphur Springs West Virginia thank you
so much Chris